foreign
nice to see you
um
seems like you brought a few folks with
you if you'd like to introduce them as
well and yes
it's all yours thank you very much and
thank you for having us we're happy to
be here on this Friday morning I like
the Valentine's Day tie good reminder
the next holiday
um I'm Sarah Stewart I serve as
commissioner of the New Hampshire
Department of Natural and cultural
resources and with me today are the
directors of the five divisions that
make up this agency and I will ask them
to each say their name and introduce
themselves right now
morning I'm Brian Wilson the director of
the division of Parks and Recreation
I'm Michael York
director of the division of live
I'm Jenny Luffy I'm the director of the
New Hampshire State Council on the Arts
good morning Ben Wilson I'm the director
of the division of historical resources
and State Storage reservations
good morning I'm Patrick Hackney the
director for the division of forest and
Lance
thank you
we have the new
we have the new Brad Simkins and the new
Phil Bryce
if you can imagine that
[Laughter]
um
um so what I thought we would do today
Mr chairman is I would take some time to
share with you what I presented to the
governor's budget director which gives a
nice overview of what we're looking to
achieve in the 2024-25 biennium and then
we can have a conversation and take
questions typically I would be sitting
next to our
um our business administrator Chris
Moreno he is not here today he's out
sick but if there are any questions that
we cannot answer I'll be sure to get
back to you and in your packet there is
information on each individual division
as well as some charts and graphs that
break down our overall Department budget
so with that I'm just going to share
with you
um the presentation I gave on November
29th to the governor's budget team
as we just mentioned we're home to five
divisions and our Collective mission is
to protect preserve promote and manage
the state's natural and cultural
resources supporting the New Hampshire's
high quality of life and strengthening
the experience of our residents and
guests
the dncr employs nearly 1 000 people
each year we manage over 220 000 Acres
of public land and maintain
approximately 870 buildings of various
types and with total value reaching
nearly 50 million dollars we also
maintain 22 Bridges 15 fire Towers 26
dams
149 septic systems 91 waterways and over
300 miles of roads and parking lots and
we are now in in the middle of our
winter season where we oversee the
management of 7 000 miles of snowmobile
trails
our agency's broad scope of services is
also Illustrated in how we touched the
daily lives of our citizens in every
community of the state our programs
grants and services have only expanded
as a result of the covid pandemic for
example the division of historical
resources required project review and
compliance program experienced a 30
percent increase
growth is the key word in this budget
request our state parks have seen
significant growth in attendance online
reservations camping and retail sales to
respond to this growth our State Park
season has grown to 36 weeks opening
earlier in the spring and staying open
beyond Columbus Day
similarly the division of forests and
lands is also experiencing growth we've
helped to conserve several thousand more
Acres available for public access and
our forest rangers are seeing a lot more
activity consistent with the growth in
outdoor recreation
for the fifth season running seedling
sales at the New Hampshire State Forest
Nursery in boscoin continue to outpace
the previous year's marks
sales income increased 52 percent from
2021's record-breaking season and
reflected a
146.7 percent increase since 2018.
the total number of orders was up 37.6
percent from last year which is just
about double 96.5 percent compared to
five years ago
the number of seedlings seedlings lifted
sorted for Quality packaged and sold
increased 50.8 percent from 2021 a 135.2
percent jump from 2018.
in order to respond to this overall
growth we have evaluated our staffing
needs and are requesting permission to
convert eight nine T positions into
full-time positions within parks and 190
to permanent full-time within the
division of historical resources we
would also like to add an additional
forest ranger and an additional Forester
to assist us in monitoring over 270
000 Acres of private land under
conservation easements
I'm also seeking your support for three
positions in the office of the
commissioner
this agency relies on the legal advice
of the Attorney General's office over
the past several years it's become
increasingly clear that with the number
of contracts lease agreements rulemaking
and day-to-day interactions with the
public there is enough work to support a
full-time agency attorney
I've discussed this need with the doj's
attorneys that have been assigned to us
and they wholeheartedly agree
another full-time position I wish to
fill with your support is a dncr
financial analyst specializing in
Federal grant Administration
from the land and water conservation
fund to the National Endowment for the
Arts and the U.S forest Service are five
divisions administer millions of federal
grants every year and rather than
continue to oversee a very siled attempt
to pull this off each grant grant round
our staff would benefit from the support
of a centralized service position and I
suspect the team at Das would also
appreciate the efficiency of working
with a central point person rather than
the many individual Grant administrators
sprinkled throughout our agency
finally a position I have advocated for
in the past and truly believe will be a
game changer for us is having a dncr
curator
as part of our mission we are to provide
access to the many Treasures that we
manage this includes artwork historic
items archaeological finds collections
that have been donated to us and more
my vision is to hire someone who can
help us organize our treasures and then
help to develop public-facing exhibits
and programs at our State library at our
parks and historic sites and even
traveling exhibits to schools local
public libraries and other community
centers
we are currently seeking a consultant
through the RFQ process to access the
state library's current space and
provide us with a plan to to store much
of the stacks in a climate-controlled
storage facility freeing up valuable
space for exciting and endless
opportunities to engage the public
other considerations in this budget
request include accounting for dramatic
increases in our utility expenses and
inter-agency transfers
something I would like to point out for
discussion is the fact that since 2007
when the Bureau of historic sites was
created it was General funded
this was done on purpose in order to
dedicate funds to the stewardship and
management of our designated historic
sites separating them from Parks funding
which was which has ebbed and flowed
over the years
historic sites also have a separate
Mission from Parks which is telling the
stories of who we are through buildings
Landscapes Collections and Exhibits
two years ago when we were asked to cut
our overall general fund budget we did
so without compromising our commitment
to the Bureau of historic sites instead
we shifted Park revenue over which you
will see as what we did again this
budget
shifting back to General funds is
something we would like to discuss
further
looking at our prioritized needs we are
making these requests consistent with
our theme of growth and demand New
Hampshire's artists cultural
organizations and for-profit venues were
hit very hard during the pandemic and
are not fully recovered a recent survey
of 53 non-profit grantees
most of which receive Art Council
operating support showed 2022 earned
Revenue to date at 78 of the
pre-pandemic levels this is consistent
with natural National Trends and is
troubling
additional State assistance will be
needed for the fiscal year 2425 biennium
as they reorient their business models
to what may be the new normal
we are also seeing an opportunity to
push Beyond critical needs to support
the state's cultural Assets in a way
that fulfills The increased demand from
the public throughout this sector
specifically requests for operating
support have increased significantly as
organic organizations mature and become
eligible for Grants applications to this
two-year program increased 30 percent in
fiscal year 2223 over the previous
biennium
requests to the Arts and health grant
program have also increased a 33 percent
increase we project continued growth in
this program as pandemic recovery
continues particularly in the areas of
behavioral health and substance misuse
services
due to this growth we are requesting a
new grants coordinator position to lead
this program
the Arts entrepreneurial grant program
continues to grow as artists build the
build and diversify their careers and
small businesses
and there is a marked need for capacity
building support for the emerging Arts
organizations particularly in the areas
of financial management and fund
development
much as the state allocated funds to
boost outdoor recreation to meet the
needs of the public we see similar
demand and opportunity within the Arts
you will also see a request to support
New Hampshire public television
historically New Hampshire PBS was
supported by the state through UNH 2.7
million annually but funding was
eliminated in 2011.
New Hampshire PBS will utilize the
requested funds to provide the state and
country with engaging local content that
showcases the state's Rich natural
cultural historical and environmental
resources
some of the programming New Hampshire
PBS will produce include our music and
arts Heritage and how it impacts the New
Hampshire economy
documentaries about New Hampshire's
hidden history
are diverse new populations the vibrant
Farm to Table movement and much more
the amount requested will simply pass
through our agency to New Hampshire PBS
but by allocating it to the council in
the Arts we can count this money towards
our federal match this is a strategic
way to make every dollar work hard for
New Hampshire
in conclusion the dncr has sustained
substantial growth over the past few
years and in order to move ahead on this
trajectory we have identified specific
opportunities to put the pedal to the
metal while staying within the three
percent general fund growth limitation
and by offsetting the new positions we
need with several vacant positions that
we can abolish
and with that
I open this to conversation
are there questions for the commissioner
representative McGuire thank you Mr
chairman thank you commissioner yes tell
me more about this Federal match what
qualifies how much do you get what their
maximums and minimums and so on thank
you so much I'm going to let um Jenny
loopy who oversees our Nea
Grant opportunity speak to that because
it's a consistent annual conversation
about how we will reach a match so that
we can maintain the uh the the amount of
money that's available to us
Jenny do you want to speak to that
should come up
yeah all these are being taped and
broadcast so we need you at the mic
thanks
first name is Ginny
g-i-n-n-i-e and the last name is Lupi l
u p as in Paul I
so we have to match dollar for dollar
every dollar that we receive from the
National Endowment for the Arts so we
have an annual process that we go
through with the Nea to apply for
partnership funds we expect in our next
Grant to receive close to 935 thousand
dollars
and so over the years we have become
very creative in how we make that match
because our general fund allocation has
been historically very low
we
count our general fund allocation we
also manage the state's percent for art
program and that is a program that Ebbs
and flows depending on uh
construction of new state buildings or
Renovations so we would use whatever we
get that year in projects toward the
match we also count the Moose plate Arts
conservation Grant funds that we receive
toward the match and so by requesting an
increase in our state grants line in
this budget we will be able to
comfortably make our match without
having to rely on Revenue sources that
are not consistent
all right
follow up yeah so
you said make your match does that mean
there's a maximum amount that could be
matched
yes we have to match our Federal grant
dollar for dollar so if we receive 935
000 from the Nea in a particular year we
have to match that with State funds
no that's not my my question is suppose
we spent two million dollars would the
FED send us two million dollars or not
no okay
unfortunately not so so our our amount
is is exactly 935
000 yes
that's the amount that we have to match
we would gratefully accept more funds
from the state for us to be able to
Grant out into the community all right
so my question is if we gave you a
million would they match a million no no
that's a it's exactly that yeah all
right and if we gave you 500
000 they would give you 500 000. yes um
no no it really works the other it's the
other way around so the National
Endowment for the Arts makes a
determination based on a formula that
they use to Grant funds to State Arts
agencies and then is it up it is up to
the state to match whatever we get from
the federal government
correct
so are you saying it's either 935
000 or zero
no we actually in the years that we were
completely unable to make the match we
applied for waivers with the National
Endowment for the Arts to be able to be
able to continue to receive that Federal
money
please also what Jenny's um expressing
is if we don't if we know we're not
going to get 935
000 from the general fund we then we
then account for the Moose plate fund
the percent for Arts which is an RSA
that says if the state builds a new
public building one half of one half one
half of one percent of that cost goes
into
um uh going out to bid to local artists
to come up with a piece of artwork for
that building that allocation can be
counted as part of the match but we
can't predict that number every year so
it's that's where the creativity comes
we try really hard to match match it
dollar for dollar if we can't then we're
shorting ourselves from that National
Funds
I see yeah so well we're about to build
a 25 million dollar parking garage
that's 250 000 in percent here all right
yeah so all right let's try again so is
does the 935 000 is that 2023's number
is it the bienniums number
what was it last biennium so we we are
expecting an increase of about a hundred
and twelve thousand dollars for Federal
fiscal year 23 which will support our
fiscal year 24 activities
I want to ask about the Tramway yeah at
some point yeah let me let me just quick
all right
so this this uh public television thing
um
that's asking for 2.7 million
no
no that the the 2.7 million is what
historically the state allocated to PBS
through UNH that was cut off
in 2011. so they have not received any
state funding since 2011. right so they
have asked
um
or is it I think 500 500 000 per year
2024 and 500 000 2025 to come to them
from the state through the Council on
the Arts which is where we can then
count
500 000 in 2024 and 500 000 in 2025 to
match the federal money which is a huge
relief
because we can benefit from that match
well it doesn't sound that way to me but
anyway all right why don't we go to the
Tramway yeah
all right
so uh there's a bill to spend 25 million
dollars
um for improving the Tramway or
something for operations what's the
situation there and and uh how has
maintenance is is this a problem that
maintenance was not adequate over time
no no no no something like that so
and then I'll ask um director Wilson to
help me
um and I apologize we had a fact sheet
that um we presented at the hearing SB
55 hearing and I didn't even think
to bring it today but I can email it out
and it's on our website so
in 1934
uh the state legislature
um agreed that the tram would be a a
magnificent tourist attraction in New
Hampshire and supported funding the tram
and it was built which really kicked off
um summer tourism as well as supporting
the ski industry in Franco de naturally
Park
fast forward to 1977 when they realized
they needed to read that trans lifespan
was over again went to the legislature
again they supported it and in 1980 uh
the tram2 which you can write today was
established
with a 40-year life expectancy we're now
at 43 years starting two years ago we
started bringing this need forward in
our Capital discussions
um so that it wouldn't be a sudden need
we would have time to do some studies
and we have so we have spoken at length
to the uh the company that manages the
equipments doppelmeyer which is fun to
say and they warn us that while the tram
is safe right now and we check it every
day the parts are so Antiquated that
when they break we're not going to be
able to find replacement parts so we
have confidence that the tram is going
to run just fine this this season the
summer season which brings us two
million dollars in revenue for the state
park system
and we want to be able to um
well we're asking the legislature to
decide is this something that New
Hampshire wants to invest in again
and if so
um working with Das and their division
of Public Works the ballpark number that
they put forward is 25 million dollars
um and that's where we're turning for
help to decipher where does that come
from we brought it before Gopher for
arpa funds we've brought it to the
capital budget just by saying we don't
know where this where you want to
allocate These funds from and so where
we are today is
at a decision point where we hit the
85th Anniversary of the tram this summer
and we would like Clarity on where we're
going to go for the next 45 years with
the tram
thank you sure so
um if if the tram was was
discontinued does that end skiing at
Cannon altogether absolutely not oh okay
so Cannon Mountain which is part of
Franconia Notch State Park runs the tram
in the winter time maybe three days a
week it supplements the skiing it's
another place for skiers to find
Adventure all those Trails can be
accessed by other lifts as well
the tram the trams busy season and where
we gain the revenue is in the spring
summer and fall
where we have busloads of of tourists
and um and people who you know go to the
bed and breakfast and say what should we
do today
how much revenue does the tram bring in
per year two point something million a
year
so that seems reasonable to continue now
to me this sounds like a capital budget
obvious sort of thing have have you gone
to the public works committee and they
turned you down so the capital budget is
only a certain amount every year right
they have 120 million to spend yes so
they were hoping that there was another
Magic Bullet
all right thank you
25 million seems to be like the number
that we've heard on a lot of projects
yeah
so further questions of the commissioner
I I have a few good
so you mentioned a number of new
positions I didn't tally them all up how
many folks are you looking to add to the
Department
so
the three new full-time positions I that
I um described for the commissioner's
office
um are
we can abolish three positions for those
three
um the nine T's that we would want to
change over to full time
would be counted as additional I guess
even though they already are people but
we want to make them full-time and then
there are two uh division of forests and
lands new positions and one Arts
position so
all things being equal it's three
new positions above and beyond what we
currently have okay
so representative Murray had a question
she asked me to ask you and that's on
the Mansion over in Newcastle the
wedding the old Governor's Mansion oh
yeah how I guess there was some activity
planned last year to do some renovation
and she was just kind of curious where
everything stood and if you need
additional funding for
upgrade and so this is the Wentworth
Coolidge Mansion
um if you haven't been you must go it's
amazing uh we just did some work
um in interior work to replace the
historic wallpaper
um which uh which was a major and
impressive overhaul of that room and
experience I'm looking at Brian Wilson
who's our historic expert in the room to
see if he has specific updates on other
projects
um so the Wentworth Coolidge Mansion
um the Billiards room as it's known uh
just had uh its wallpaper
um uh redone it was a room where
actually
um a silverfish will eat paper they they
like
um cellulose and that entire room of
18th century wallpaper was eaten over
the last last 50 years and so that room
um was completely done
um the floor all the painting the
wallpaper plaster work there is other
work going on right now which is the
repair of the sea wall which protects
the easternmost side of the foundation
to the building
and then there's other work planned
um that will come out of a historic
structures report that's being done I
believe this spring and that is to look
at all of the Interior
um deal with moisture issues
um uh freshen up the paint on the
interior as well as do some other
wallpaper conservation work it still has
its original 18th century flocked
wallpaper in two rooms which is
um I think there are four rooms in
America that still have these um these
papers on them and and we own one of
them
thank you not just for him not specific
what is a tax credit project
uh so
um through the National Park Service if
um you were to buy a historic building
down on Main Street here
um or even this building
um and you wanted to put it into uh
commercial use you can apply through our
office
for a historic uh 20 historic uh tax
credit
um so
um uh it's a it's a very popular program
amongst developers who want to retain
the historic nature of a building but
also make it useful today and add the
modern amenities and that sort of thing
so we work in consultation with the
developer and The Architects to make
that happen
is that 20 of the purchase price of the
building or the the amount the work done
to fix it up of the appraised value
after the work is done
oh I see and is it sort of automatic
that
uh it uh it yes it can be um it's a it's
a length assuming you did the work
correctly and that sort of thing and
that's why we work very closely
um with uh with the folks doing the work
and and how what the scope is and that
sort of thing and then we send off all
of that information to the park service
and they actually do the approvals the
final approvals but it's a very popular
project program yeah
representative McGuire is our resident
engineer which
is very thorough yeah very thorough
thank you very much
so I guess I have a couple of questions
on the Bureau of trails
so the division has been actually
wrestling with an issue over in Dairy
it's the trail the rail trail it runs
from Salem to Manchester and this little
stub that's
lacking connectivity I guess would be
the right word and there's a
rather a contentious issue between the
town and the rail trail people and the
bicyclists and I'm asking you this
question because the commissioner got
involved with a very contentious issue
in Peterborough
where we had uh issues with the D.O.T
the puc and eversource and it took about
five years right that we got all the
people together and came up with a
solution that everybody was happy with
which was amazing and I got to give
Sarah a lot of credit because it the
initial stage we were told that the her
Department had no say-so really in the
issue it was a p-u-c-d-o-t issue and
when it came around Sarah stepped up
we have people involved with the um
Trails people in the area and uh it
worked out well so how do as far as
managing these state-owned
Trails is the trail from Manchester to
Salem is that I know some of it's owned
by the state or how does that all work
as far as your agency in the trails
Bureau managing these Trails it is so
complicated oh here we go
um
I can't speak specifically to the Salem
Manchester one but what I can say is
what you described illustrates a common
challenge around the state the good news
is there are a lot of people that value
our trail system right for a variety of
reasons and we should have room for
everybody we should have room for people
who want to walk their dog and people
who want to ride their fat bikes in the
winter and people who want to ride their
machines
so we have the Bureau of trails that is
within the division of Parks and
Recreation
and that Bureau is I'll be honest mostly
focused on motorized vehicle trails
because that's where their funding comes
from registrations from snowmobiles and
ATVs we have decided as a department
that we need to pay
out of a Parks fund for a full-time
employee to help manage the
non-motorized activity on our Trails
because currently there is not a a phone
number at a desk where non-motorized
constituents feel like they have an
advocate in the state agency we work
with them closely we partner with them
they're they're represented on our state
uh you know Committees of advisors for
the trails Etc but but it's it's getting
busy out there and more complicated we
work very closely with DOT because they
do have a lot of jurisdiction over the
rail trails that you articulated and
they have invested a lot of time and
hired a consulting firm to come up with
a vision for rail trail development
throughout the state and our staff is
working in concert with that that's a
long-term plan A lot of these challenges
are just sort of whack-a-mole right now
to try to figure out how we can find
solutions that work for local
constituents and sometimes it works out
fine and sometimes it's more it's more
complicated one of the requests that we
put forth for arpa funds and it was
approved and now we're working through
the process of making our Dream Come
True is
um
creating a GIS mapping tool for state
agencies and municipalities decision
makers to be all on the same page when
we're having conversations about Trails
right now there is not a comprehensive
Current Online mapping tool for all of
the trails in New Hampshire and we need
to make decisions in real time based on
safety if a trail is washed out and you
know Fish and Game needs to know that we
have to close this part of the trail we
also have to make decisions based on
private landowner rights state issues
conservation easements and so having one
comprehensive color-coded place where we
can update information in real time and
prioritize these types of conversations
will be a game changer I think for the
trails system in New Hampshire in the
meantime like I said it is complicated
and we're having a lot of one-off
conversations
representative hatch followed by
representative McGuire okay thank you
thank you in terms of enforcement for
the trails
I get a lot of activity with in my
district over this and I get a lot of
constituent calls with people
um either confused or unsure of where
they need to go for enforcement type of
activities and things they need
addressed and who do they contact local
police the fish and game or whomever and
they've been told all of the above
depending on the circumstance
so if we
as we're increasing the trails in the
activity on them has there been any
effort to uh put Clarity to this or what
is the appropriate venue uh because I've
had a plethora of Interest yeah
um inquiring about this
for enforcement or even just information
before having trouble finding the right
person to talk to about what they
shouldn't is there a lot of this yeah
exactly exactly so
so where does that sit I guess thank you
uh great question uh we have a wonderful
working relationship with the fish and
game
um and it's a daily conversation between
their CEOs who are out in the woods and
are forest rangers that are also out in
the woods so in our division of forest
and lands and you see I because of the
growth of activity in in The Great
Outdoors we are seeking an additional
forest ranger to help because we did a
an informal audit among our forest
rangers just to get an understanding of
what percentage of their time is being
spent on trail
um issues and they with confidence say
about 20 and that's a new number for
them this wasn't usually it's not a
typical or historic um piece of work for
them uh so our forest rangers and our
CEOs are out in the woods
uh and when they can it's it's a lot of
Education we have people renting the
machinery and they don't realize they're
on private land and they're here for a
weekend and then they're going to go
back and so there's a a real push to
educate the respect for the land
um that they're recreating on it to
understand that so we're having that
conversation the CEOs
are doing the best they can I'm sure
director Mason can speak to his needs
um in terms of his his troop uh and then
when it comes to towns that have agreed
to allow Vehicles ATVs on their actual
town roads uh that comes that comes down
to their own town law abilities and some
towns are recognizing I think dumberston
voted down the opportunity because they
don't have law enforcement on their
roads
um so it would be challenging we our
forest rangers aren't on town roads
pulling people over so we're just in the
woods so may I just along this um where
does the sheriff's department for
different counties intersect with this
because there's a I think there's needs
to be some clarity to the subject and
I'm not sure the best way
um best laws are yeah the best method to
get there but it is a problem
not only do we work closely with the
sheriffs the county sheriffs but many of
the county sheriff's staff come from the
Bureau of trails and forests and land
staff so we know them personally
um but uh there has there has to be you
know sort of documented agreements and
understanding of what we can supplement
and what they can supplement which is an
exercise that we go through in real time
I'm looking at director Patrick Hackley
I don't know if you want to say anything
about coax County at this point because
he's had these conversations over the
last couple months with kowas County
which you can imagine is very busy in
this Arena
um sure I can project from the back you
know unfortunately you've got to use
some mic otherwise
um and just your full name and with
spelling please
Patrick Hackley director for the
division of forest and Lance
so as commissioner Stewart said
um
my most of my experience now in terms of
uh interaction between the sheriff the
County Sheriff's Office and our Rangers
is kawas County so we'll just use that
as the primary example
the Sheriff's Office up in co-host does
a darn good job of policing the trails
they have the bandwidth as as
Commissioners said they also have three
of our retired Rangers that work for
their office so they know the back roads
they know the trails and I and I believe
that the Sheriff's Office and their
deputies have a good working
relationship also with Fish and Game
conservation officers so there's three
enforcement entities out there on the
trails in the North country as you can
imagine
they're all needed because of the the
capacity that those trails get they get
a tremendous amount of use
so I believe our relationship is pretty
solid uh with uh the county sheriff's
office
um but they are needed uh uh enforcement
agency when it comes to the trails and
speeding and registrations and things
like that
um
and I'm sure that the CEOs for fish and
game could say the same thing that that
it's a welcomed participation but as of
right now we don't have any formal mou
with the sheriff's office that might be
something we
explore but we have in our fiscal year
24 25 budget requested another Ranger
and that this ohrv Enforcement issue is
specifically one of the reasons we're
asking for to to add another Ranger
um so yeah
um
on this line
yes sir
you don't have a
memorandum of understanding which I
would I thought one was being developed
goes back in koas County yes a year ago
I mean but I undoubtedly was given
um I think it was a good idea if there
was but I'm not aware that one was in
play okay and here here goes to my query
and my concern is is um
who's coordinating this and that's what
needs to happen is that something uh
seems like your agency has most of the
problems with with this activity so is
this something you're coordinating of
course the sheriff's department thinks
they I think it's done very much so at
the local level so the sheriff the
sheriff uh will speak with our chief so
Chief Steve Sherman he's the head of our
forest Protection Bureau and that's
that's where our Rangers that's that's
the the bureau that they work under so I
believe those conversations occur
between
the sheriff the county sheriff our chief
and then I think it's Mike Eastman Mike
Eastman with the wild so the three of
them communicate and however they work
it out I have not heard of any
particular conflicts
between the agencies but it I think it's
this good relationship housekeeping
maybe and I'd be willing to explore an
mou if that's what you're recommending
if I may I think I think um that might
be a good opportunity I think that
should be explored it's just I don't
necessarily get feedback from the
sheriff's department or the Rangers
um I get feedback from constituents and
people who utilize it and and
um concerns about they lack direction as
to what yeah
is correct or what they should or
shouldn't be doing sure you know I mean
in my mind it's common sense but yeah
well we would like that to Prevail
usually but it doesn't always especially
out in the ohrv trails right but um what
what era do you represent what's your
question
oh yeah oh yeah well there you go yeah
that Gorham
yeah okay so that is that is the county
of of interest when it comes to HRV and
snowmobile enforcement
um I'm open to that we've been working
with the Sheriff's Office not so much
with the fish and wildlife because I
think they have their routes that they
Patrol
it's it's not uh just just to be clear
though
um we do it because our as the
commissioner said our staff is out in
the woods already that's where their
enforcement jurisdiction is particularly
on dncr lands but also on private lands
when it comes to forestry laws and
Wildfire prevention and suppression so
those are the two pillars of their
enforcement Forestry uh water quality
violations in partnership with Des so if
they discover logging jobs are affecting
water quality they reach out to Des and
then any any Wildfire activity fire
permits Etc ohrvs has crept into their
their Suite of enforcement duties
because of the nature of the you know
the explosion of that that sport
particularly in the North Country so
um
yeah I mean I I think it's probably a
good idea I'm going to be presenting to
the uh the cause County delegation
actually uh you'll probably be there on
the 27th on Monday uh the 27th so
um
I'm willing to explore that conversation
if you think it would help if if your
constituents are concerned about
bad behavior on the trails than than the
three enforcement agencies should be
talking saying who's going to be where
this weekend that kind of thing I think
that's it makes sense just one more uh
concern along that venue
um you you take care of the registration
who takes what agency Fish and Game
takes care of the registration so um
what happens is there's a
ohrvs out there with non-appropriate
equipment on them and make noise or they
don't have the proper noise
um we
Mufflers or whatever so uh fishing game
is the primary source for that but okay
good we'll see okay thank you all right
thank you
represent McGuire thank you Mr chair so
on the mapping project of trails are you
doing that with the granite system
are you familiar with that so we are in
uh We've convened sort of the gis
experts from all the agencies that are
using GIS to figure out what what the
bet we don't want to start something new
if there's a platform that we can
already use we've talked to 9-1-1 we've
talked to dot we've talked to uh fish
and game so I don't know what the
current iteration of that conversation
is but we certainly aren't doing this
without consultation with other say
agencies to get something that will work
for everybody yeah because that system
is fantastic it's
g-r-a-n-i-t no e yeah right and it's got
layers for
um topology and Roads and all this sort
of stuff and you can choose what layers
you want to see at any given time and
you could easily have a snowmobile layer
and a trail layer and you know all that
kind of thing I'm with with certainty I
can say that that has been a
conversation yeah okay good now as long
as you're here we're running out of time
um
your agency takes in a lot of Revenue
right so can you give us the big picture
kind of number of what's your Revenue
versus your total expenses annually
um
I don't know if we have
so other funds right other funds what
are other funds well other funds mostly
in our agency are the revenues that we
generate through Parks and Recreation
and if you look at the pie charts you
can see DNC are other fund Source mix
Parks and Recreation 80 percent
of their funding is other funds which
means Revenue force and lands you know
almost five million dollars of Revenue
so a bulk of of the
um
uh well by RSA state parks have to be
operationally self-funded so in order to
open a park in order to clean the
bathrooms in order to hire an employee
and give them a give them a uniform we
need to charge at the door to get in
um and so our number one
funding source as you can imagine
93 state parks only half of them we
charge at
and of that half only half make make a
profit
so we really lean on Franconia Notch
state park for their extra Revenue we
really lean on Hampton Beach for the
parking revenue and there's other
Pawtuckaway other state parks that do
well enough that they can chip in to
support the other state parks it's our
mission to be accessible so we don't
want to have escalating rates all the
time to
um to deter a family of four from
Manchester to have a wonderful Park
experience we want to be affordable and
that's part of our mission so we we run
ourselves like a business in the Parks
department and as I alluded to in my
remarks a lot of our forests and lands
are our enterprise system there is
growing and we want to capture that
what's the yeah thank you what is the
Commissioner's Office pie what does that
consist I was looking at that myself I I
run a bake sale every you know
um I'm gonna have to get back to you on
that one specifically
um because I do not sell things from
that commissioner and then and then this
whole circle is the red one to the right
right so other fans the other funds and
then there's federal funds and you have
14 General correct business is good
we're we're doing a good job
um and we reflect uh that in my remarks
with recognizing if we want to sustain
it we need to you know hire where where
it's strategically important
thank you
representative Griffin
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
the question
I've always um I see here that we have 3
700 plus a minus archaeological sites
and um
I've always wondered what what makes a
site what is the criteria of the site to
make it
archaeological oh good question I'm a
little trouble with big words yeah so
um one of our best kept secrets is that
we this division this department is home
to our state archaeologists um and
they're amazing and they have so many
treasures and as a mom of three little
kids it kills me that we're not taking
these treasures and bringing them to
every school in the state because it's
really remarkable
um we I'll let Ben speak to the science
behind Discerning an archaeological site
but uh you know well I'll just let him
explain it because I'm not a scientist
thank you
it's a great question
um so you can stick a shovel anywhere in
New Hampshire in the ground and come up
with a archaeological site basically but
these are sites that have actually been
dug
um and recorded so for instance whenever
dot does a highway widening project
there's an archaeological component to
it as well as above ground resource
components so if there's a stone wall
that has to be moved or or a Cellar hole
something like that so each time a
project like that is taken on it creates
another site basically there are some
more important sites
pre-contact sites we have 12 500 years
of history of inhabitants in New
Hampshire and
those are more specific sites where
um it's somebody an archaeologist
looking to to frame the history of of
that certain group of people
how they moved around and lived and that
sort of thing so I I guess I was
wondering if there's a criteria
you know so many years of
what the criteria is
um
to um to actually call it a an
archaeological site you know that's a
good question that might be above my pay
grade I'm not an archaeologist a trained
archaeologist I'm an architectural
historian preservationist and I can
certainly get that information to you
but archaeologists like to think that
you know the beer can that's thrown out
the car window
could possibly be an archaeological site
at some at some point
um so it's um I think it's a fairly
vague
um definition
um but we spend a lot of our time
um looking at at archeology as it
pertains to federally uh funded and
state-funded uh projects around the
state
representative Griffin probably has what
the largest license plate collection
around and so his site might be
considered an archaeological site
representable Mr
alternating so
um thank you for the question
um so we do maintain an archeology lab a
laboratory uh and I I won't mention
where it is but
um uh just for safety sake and um but we
we curate all of the things that are
found in the state from all of these
projects for other agencies as well as
for our own agency and
um it's uh vastly
um
uh under uh well it's over utilized and
um and we do need more space
um it's our hope that um that we'll be
able to move into a another building
actually at the same location
um temporarily
um but um it's it's really our Dream
it's our commissioner's dream to create
um to create basically a museum for all
of the things that we have we have
artwork we have collections we have all
of our archeology uh bits and pieces
which are are fascinating and um and
we'd like to Showcase those uh to the
citizens of New Hampshire and and our
visitors
so um but our archeology lab and I'm
happy to give a tour uh the state
archaeologist would be happy to give a
tour to anybody that wants to see that
that facility uh it's here in Concord
any further questions I do have one
quick question for I think the Forester
so I've read that we've got an invasive
species issue that all sorts of insects
are coming and plant life what are you
doing to deal with those issues I know
it's a big concern for commissioner
Jasper with agriculture but what are you
folks doing sure
so in your folders that we provided
there's a snapshot of our division and
the different units that are under uh
the force and lands
uh one of them is called the Forest
Health
it's actually not officially a bureau
but we treat it as such it's Forest
Health Program
so we have three full-time Professionals
in that program
and their responsibility is to do
monitoring research and mitigation on
invasive species
um the legislature several years ago
appropriated a significant amount of
funds that funded one of our
entomologists on staff to specifically
address the invasion of the emerald ash
borer I think everyone's pretty familiar
with that by now where we we're losing
or we'll likely lose most of our mature
white ash trees in New Hampshire
um I don't want to get into that issue
specifically but we have been working on
that for a number of years introducing
parasitic wasps
tiny small in your pinky fingernail that
actually feed on the larvae of the the
emerald ash borer and so we're releasing
and these parasitic wasps are
specifically Target they that's what
they feed on they're that's the only
thing they feed on so even though we're
introducing another uh foreign species
that's the first question people ask are
we gonna have problems with the WASP but
what they found the researchers did
their full research before they started
breeding and distributing these
parasitic wasps
to basically naturalize and because the
animal dashboard is here to stay it's
also naturalized so we needed to
naturalize a predator and that was the
the purpose and this is why we have
professional entomologists that study
insects bug scientists we call them
sometimes Pathologists that study tree
diseases
um and uh you'll be pleased to know in
terms of Forest Health that the U.S
forest Service has granted us additional
funding which is not baked into this
fiscal year 2425 budget because we're
we're asked by the by the budget office
by Das not to include it but we'll have
another hundred thousand dollars to
apply towards Forest health issues in
fiscal year 24-25 and we've already come
up with a game plan for that so we we're
very actively engaged in in the forest
Health invasive species issues
all right I I know that there was a wasp
that went after gypsy moth I don't know
if that was introduced naturally or
somebody brought it in but we had that
infestation of gypsy moth several years
ago and it was developed to go after the
eggs or something okay yeah
um
I'm not sure about a predator for gypsy
moth now that's basically been
naturalized for decades and and we've
had a spike recently of gypsy moth
infestation in the Conway area it's
actually a very they've documented this
our our staff has they've documented
where it often is like a band that goes
diagonally across the state and kind of
tops out in Temple New Hampshire for
some reason
but um there's a natural fungus that
that um
destroys the larvae of the the
caterpillar so when we have droughty
Summers that fungus is not allowed to
spread like it usually does and so we
see a spike in the Gypsy moth population
after some droughty Summers that's
that's what we believe that's what our
forest Pathologists believe is occurring
with gypsy moth right now fortunately
they feed mostly on Oak Oak is very
resilient and most defeating is done by
the end of June
an oak can re-sprout a second set of
leaves by the end of the summer so but
successive defoliations
like two to three Summers of heavy
defoliation we can lose some trees so
we're watching that
all right any further questions uh
commissioner
great to see you good to see you
you know um specifically about Gorham
we're about to open a new office in
Gorham we um the Department of
Environmental Services has uh has had a
building there for a number of years
they didn't need it anymore and they
were going to sell it and we said hold
on we would love to have our imprint in
Gorham because it is such a critical
spot for not only outdoor recreation but
a cultural assets too so you'll see an
invitation this summer for a grand
opening of a building that everyone
knows in Gorham but I'm really excited
to expand our visibility and
connectivity Beyond Concord and I think
this is a really good opportunity
all right seeing no further questions
but if for our budget discussion when
you come back would you put together the
economic value of our trail system to
the state's economy I know it's
significant we heard about 160 000
people use the Salem rail trail and
several businesses have developed on the
trail so I'd be curious if you could put
something together to give us an idea
exactly what this trail system is
providing economically to the states
probably a big chore but
you got a couple weeks for you anything
we'll we'll get that we'll get it
all right thank you
sure representative yeah sorry I'm sorry
I came in late
on state parks I know you guys really
live on fees do you have staffing issues
at parks where you could be collecting
fees but you don't have the staff to do
it
yeah we make strategic decisions
um not every year but as as patterns
change and different parks are
discovered on what the economic
viability is of having a staff person
there or not some of our parks where we
don't have a staff person we have an
iron Ranger where people can leave
donations which we collect and um and
that's wonderful but yeah it's
if we had more stuff we would have more
staff at parks that don't have stuff
it's a short answer
I guess it I I it's probably really hard
to quantify but it's one of those things
where if you had more staff you could
yeah yeah we you know we're focused
um on critical positions like lifeguards
you know it would be tragic if we hit
the summer season at Hampton Beach and
we didn't have enough lifeguards we hire
73 lifeguards these are very busy people
as you can imagine at Hampton Beach so
right now we're recruiting those so we
put a lot of effort in Recruitment and
retainment and our primary focus on are
on some of these Life Safety positions
and then beyond that looking at other
other spots that we would love to
to hire I while we're talking see how
this is how quick we are there is some
um value allocated to Trails Bureau and
local clubs deliver an additional
economic impact of 586 million to the
state annually and we estimate the ATV
use use generates over another 500
million in addition third parties
generate six million in revenue for
their organizations through events held
in state parks I will take this number
and I'll expand a little bit on it for
you but we have a start
thanks so much
we'll see you in a couple weeks
so it's well after 11 and so we're gonna
hear from The Liquor Commission are they
here
okay
yeah coupons
and we have some distinguished guests
here today
okay
thank you
foreign
thank you commissioner
please identify yourself for our clerk
um gets we'll get started
you need to push the red button or the
button thank you
chairman members of the committee I'm
Joseph Malika I'm the chairman of the
New Hampshire Liquor Commission and with
me is Tina demirs our CFO
so I would like to bring you through a
little Department overview
of the Liquor Commission
so we can start on page two
just a basic breakdown of the three-tier
system
on page three you'll see the values and
attributes of the three-tier system
and that's uh according to the nabca the
national alcohol Bureau of control
that's a 2015 statement from them we are
a member as a control State we are a
member of the nabca
on page four you can see the 17
controlled jurisdictions across the
United States after prohibition the
federal government allowed the states to
make the choices whether they'd be open
or control States and at that time New
Hampshire along with 16 other states
made the decision to be a control
control destination
on page five you can see the operational
overview of the commission the high
points are the Liquor Commission is
self-funded it's a separate liquor fund
outside of the general fund and no
general fund Appropriations are used to
maintain the operations of the Liquor
Commission
in 2022 the commission generated up just
under 722 million dollars in sales
can move to Page Six
the divisions and responsibilities of
the commission we have the office of the
commission the division of enforcement
the division of administration and the
division of marketing and Merchandising
and descriptions of each
on page seven you can see the organ
organizational structure of the
commission again the office of the
commission and the three divisions
underneath classified and unclassified
employees that are in each
the division of marketing 298 classified
employees includes not only the folks at
the HQ warehouse but it also includes
our people
in marketing and in the stores
and may I ask are are many of those
part-time
uh not of that 298 that was their
full-time employees but in General
stores have many parts we do yeah and we
have a whole section toward the end okay
we'll go through the full and part-time
and part-time equivalent as well gotcha
thank you representative
so on page eight you'll see the
statutory uh duties of the Liquor
Commission that's uh RSA 176 colon 3
which lays out the
opportunities that the Liquor Commission
takes forth every day to run a
profitable business
on page nine
you look at the division of enforcement
they have a pre a three-pronged approach
which is Education First enforcement
second and Licensing as a third prong of
their duties
on page 10
on the right hand side you'll see the
2022 calendar year year end we have 6
700 and 18 licensees in the United
States and you can see in the breakdown
there so those are folks from across the
country and here in the states
in the state and the revenue below that
is derived from the enforcement arm of
just under 19 million dollars
on page 11
on the left hand side you'll see the
educational efforts of the enforcement
division the public awareness and
education on the left and the licensing
educational programs on the right
and a breakdown of each and everything
that we do to make the public aware of
what we're doing and the licensees
trained and as to what we're doing
on page 12.
you'll see the 2022 I'm sorry there was
a question I'm sorry representative
Griffin sorry representative thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking the
question
um I need you to go back to page 10 for
a minute sure
did you say that that number was in
state or is that usy that's usy because
we do allow direct shippers in New
Hampshire we're one of eight states that
allows the shipping of alcohol and wines
into the state uh and I'm sorry we're
one of eight states that allows the
alcohol and wine and there's 13 states
that allow wine and beer so as you can
see under direct shippers on the third
bullet down we have
1444 licensees that ship from but these
are all New Hampshire licenses no sir
these licenses the direct shipper
licenses are licensees from outside the
state of New Hampshire but but the
license allows them to sell things that
that's correct yes sir yeah so if they
have a website on their liquor store in
in Florida we allow them to ship their
product here into the state thank you
the number look low for us wide thing
okay and sure I I was assuming that
those were in New Hampshire licenses and
allowed people to come in and sell them
this thing yes sir thank you for
answering thank you representative thank
you for the question representative
McGuire thank you just a related
question is um I knew that was a long
time for wineries is alcohol new to
allow people to ship or has that always
been no alcohol since that direct
shipper's license was uh was given out
that that's allowed alcohol has been
allowed there is some uh
some
defined
requirements that allow people to ship
they can't sell it into the state less
than they can sell it that then we sell
it and they can't uh there's a there's a
level of how much they can sell from a
gallonage standpoint
I see so so there's no incentive to buy
I Don't Know Jack Daniels or something
no via Direct ship instead of in the
store right yeah exactly thank you this
was put out there for their small
boutique wineries across the country
especially in California Washington
Oregon that may only have an acre of
grapes and they may produce three or
four hundred cases a year we didn't want
we did not want our consumers to not
have the availability to those products
so we allow them to ship them into the
stain
thank you sir
so uh we'll move on to to uh page 12 and
just the 2022 trainings that were done
in the state on the left hand side
you can see the Liquor Commission
trained 4 700 people with uh the live
classes and in 2022 public awareness
events there was 67 events held
Statewide and we trained just a little
over a hundred and thirteen thousand
people at those
so education and awareness is a very
important piece of what the enforcement
division does
next we can move on to page 13 which is
the division of administration and
management
you can see that's under our CEO James
Vera and and his responsibilities of
doit or managed Information Systems
Human Resources our HR department and
financial financial management which is
everything that consumes our
transactions of product in the state
outside of the state and the moving and
paying of those products
on page 14 you'll see the division of
marketing and Merchandising and again on
the left hand side their marketing goals
by Bullet and on the right hand side the
responsibilities that fall under uh Lori
Piper who is the director of marketing
for the Liquor Commission
on page 15
you'll see the retail outlet locations
across the state
we have nine state-owned 59 leased and
we have 27 Outlets with in-store and
curbside pickup some a program that we
came up with during covet in September
of 2020 and that has garnered the state
with 7.6 million dollars in sales since
2020.
on page 16 you'll see the state owned
only outlets and at the bottom you'll
see that those Outlets have brought in
just over 164 million dollars and 27 of
our total sales are done in the
locations that we actually own the
property
on page 17
you'll see on the left the top 15 stores
of the Liquor Commission bring in 51 of
the revenue and all other stores bring
in 49 of the revenue with a tally of the
ranking stores 1 to 15 on the right hand
side
on page 18 uh just a quick listing of
our three agency stores there's one in
Greenville there's one in Pittsburgh and
there's one in Arrow and the revenue
that they bring in just a little under
2.5 million and just a quick note there
in the asterisk that arrow is being
rebuilt at this point because there was
a fire two years ago and they should be
up and running again by April we're
being told
do have a quick question commissioner I
was in Westchester field a couple weeks
back with my wife and I noticed large
volumes of well there are several Vans
loading alcohol in the back there's no
prohibition to the amount of alcohol you
can buy at a store right it's not
unlimited or or cash restricted or
anything like that no it's not and we
actually had a letter written to us
through doj from the IRS that explains
that we have no limit of cash and we
have no limit of product okay the the
state of New Hampshire is not breaking
any laws when we sell the product the
individual who buys the product when
they go back into their state they have
to claim the tax in their state but our
selling of the product you know as again
according to the IRS and according to
doj we are breaking no laws and doing
that either State and or federal
question representable
um so as far as your retail outlet and
state-owned are
solidating or are you expanding the
number of outlets or have those stayed
about the same or just think about
Staffing and all that kind of
well there's there's and we'll get into
some of this and that's fine but there
is you know obviously we have a concern
of Staffing and we have we have less
outlets now than we did 10 years ago but
we actually have more square footage so
the consolidations have taken the
smaller stores and we've opened fewer
larger locations mainly to make sure
that the consumers when they come here
they can recognize and purchase the
birth of products that we have available
because there's very few liquor
outlets in the United States that have
the amount of skews of wine and spirits
that we have
you're welcome
representative McGuire thank you so as
opposed to state-owned that just means
you lease in certain places that's
correct okay yes yeah I think
so on page 19 you'll look at the web in
e-commerce uh just under the orange
balloon there you can see that we get
about 125 000 visitors a month to our
website
and we have 200 000 recipients of our
monthly email and we gained 25
000 additional subscribers in 2022.
and on the right hand side again you'll
notice that since 2020 the curbside and
in-store pickup revenue is 7.6 million
dollars
on page 20 you'll just see some of the
monthly flyers and collaboration
the monthly Flyers are a big way there's
a lot of celebrity products today a lot
of a lot of interest in high-ends wines
and spirits so our monthly flyer which
is called voila comes out on a monthly
basis
foreign
and then we have our sales our monthly
sales which everybody has come to know
and love the 15 off 12 bottles or more
mix or match and then some of the
display work that's been done in our
Outlets including uh
products to go chilled products to go in
some locations many locations
on page 21 you'll see our keep it local
support a branding that we've partnered
with New Hampshire Wine and Spirits to
give our consumers a 20 discount on
three bottles or more of New Hampshire
made products so that is a great program
and what runs well and on the right hand
side you'll see our Google Google
reviews that 91 of our reviews are four
and five star rating and we had about
2500 reviews last year
on page 22 you'll see just quickly some
of the outlet changes that we've made
we've relocated or constructed 40 new
outlets in 35 communities a lot of them
rehabilitations and consolidations this
year alone we opened a new outlet in
wrench we opened a new outlet in
Manchester on Gold Street and we opened
a new outlet at exit 17 in Concord
and just if there's any questions on the
bottom uh bullet that's our 95 Hampton
southbound Northbound and southbound
Rehabilitation we have an appropriation
for that the Liquor Commission through
statute is allowed to sell that property
and redevelop those much like we did in
Hooksett
hopefully bigger and better
on page 23 I'm sorry
are you very alert back there sorry so I
just wanted to say that your locations
your rebuilds are very attractive you
know they fit into the community and
unlike a lot of Steel Buildings you see
going up more but I think a lot of
people appreciate the overall look of
the properties thank you representative
we tried to give it a New Hampshire
Granite Timber Peg and thank you yeah
yeah we have a very nice new one a mile
from my house so great
um yeah very convenient
um have you increased the minimum size
of a of a new location so that you never
will build one smaller than x something
like that most of the new ones that
we're building are a minimum of around 9
000 square feet and obviously running up
to 35 000 square feet depending on where
the location is we found that 10 11 12
000 is around the minimum because of the
amount of product that we need to fit in
we have a lot of skus people when they
come to New Hampshire they come to stock
up and that's the goal of people coming
here is doing that so we just want to
make sure we have a birth of products
when they get here so so the overall
average there's probably a lot of older
stores that are smaller than that nine
thousand correct yeah so so you're kind
of pushing in the bigger Direction
absolutely okay great
so you'll see on page 23 the ringe
relocation and the sales increase you
can see the sales uh the square footage
increase from 51 100 to 10 000 square
feet and the 22 percent sales increase
in that location since we've moved it in
May of 2022.
the Concord Outlet which is the new one
on exit 17 we went from four thousand
square feet over on uh
the plaza with Lowe's and Market Basket
in downtown
we have a minimal increase at this point
of two percent but the plaza is not
completed yet the Market Basket is now
open and we're uh we're looking forward
to the restaurants and other uh
like-minded retailers that will open
there
on Manchester and Gold Street uh Number
store 31 that's a new location uh
year-to-date sales are 3.3 million
dollars and obviously right there we're
next to the busiest Walmart in New
England uh so we're we're generating a
lot of traffic with between Walmart and
Hannaford
on page 26 you can see the major reason
why the the importance of doing what
we're doing building a brand and
building larger more impactful stores
governor Patrick in 2011 signed a bill
increasing the amount of liquor licenses
that one license he could hold in the
state of new state of Massachusetts so
and they're up to nine in 2020 and
there's word that they'll be increasing
that again from 9 to 11. uh 50 of our
sales uh come from out of state sales so
cross-border sales 50 percent of our
gross sales number we are now uh in
competition with the largest independent
retailer in the United States which is
Total Wine and Spirits they're out of
Bethesda Maryland
um
on page 27 you can see they have 245
stores in 27 States they do about five
billion dollars in business they have 11
000 employees since 2016 they have built
six stores in New Hampshire east of the
495 belt and they plan on two more in
2023 along with Market Basket which is
now into a
MB Liquors they're calling it they have
two or three in Maine they have two or
three in Massachusetts they're opening
four more in Massachusetts
uh they're opening two more Costco's and
one more BJs in the state
so you can see that the big box
retailers have come to do business in
New England
and uh total has stores in Connecticut
as well but Massachusetts has kind of
put out the welcome sign to alcohol
retailers to come and uh
generously compete Against The Liquor
Commission and quite frankly that's why
total's here
so they're here to do business with us
and we're still doing very well
yes representative McGuire How do prices
compare to the consumer here in New
Hampshire compared to these stores
after tax and all that uh well
Massachusetts did a couple of different
things when they signed that bill they
repealed their alcohol tax at the same
time so they were clearly Square on uh
the target was New Hampshire so they
repealed their alcohol tax and they they
did give some incentives for people
coming to the state our prices are very
competitive especially on name brand
products Total Wine is a private label
retailer so they have knockoff products
of pretty much everything that they do
across the board so they have a knockoff
of Tito's a knockoff of Jack Daniels a
knockoff of Kendall Jackson
etc etc their marketing plan is to lure
you in with low prices but they don't
have the product there where we'll have
six or seven hundred cases of Captain
Morgan's in a large tour they'll have
six and they may they may match us or
undercut by a dollar but the people that
go into buy the product the product
isn't there to buy and they are making
very little on the name brand products
we're an outlet we're all about name
brand products and their Chardonnay
that's their own private label they have
six to twelve labels that come out of
one spigot of Chardonnay so they and
they do that across the board I mean
it's widely known uh what they do and
how they do business in the industry
thank you now is Total Wine are they a
publicly traded or private company
they're owned by Two Brothers Paul and
David trone and David trone is a
congressman in the 15th District in
Maryland he was just interesting
interesting just elected he's in his
second term thanks thank you
foreign so you'll see on page
you'll see on page 28 our hb2 Liquor
Commission request in 2011 uh Governor
Lynch
approved and was into hb2 an incentive
program for the Liquor Commission it's
something you know that I've written and
we never used uh we felt that at this
time given the uh paid to S the
difference in Pay between what private
retailers are paying and what the state
is paying that it was time to enact this
retail incentive program
I did send three or four different
um variations of the program to Governor
sununu he approved one we are seeing
this go into uh hb2 this year and
basically the program has approved and
has been approved as I said since 2011
but the language on page 29 is what
we're really looking to see
that we're out of the additional profits
that are being made the Liquor
Commission will fund this program so 10
percent of the profits additional
profits will be paid to the employees
via uh via an incentive bonus so we've
broken down it down by the seven areas
in the state the seven supervisor areas
and at this point we started the program
in January and we're just looking to
have this language put in so we can pay
those employees that incentive bonus
foreign McGuire thank you so currently
does do any employees work on commission
in any way no no representative they
don't and so with this program the more
they sell the the better they'll they'll
they'll get some kind of a bonus how
does that work they anything any
increase in sales per area so we have
seven supervisor areas so if let's say
area 7 which is up north increases sales
by a million dollars in that area 10 of
that increase will go to the employees
in that area only to given an incentive
so it creates a little competition in
the stores and it also increases
employees salaries we
and I just have to be frank our our
employees in our retail outlets are
grossly underpaid compared to private
retailers in the state of New Hampshire
I mean McDonald's in Claremont the other
day when I went by was 18 an hour a free
meal with each shift twenty five hundred
dollar incentive for Education uh work
today get paid tomorrow so we're way
behind the we're behind the eight ball
on that and we're just trying to let our
employees know that we we recognize it
we understand it we're concerned about
it and we're doing something about it
how about in the benefits area I think
the benefits are are as far as part-time
employees we have no benefits for our
part-time employees our full-time
employees are are well taken care of and
in my humble opinion okay
the part-time rate starting rate is
12.63 cents an hour I see yeah yeah
that's not great and so so this
incentive is kind of a team concept
rather than you sell you do something
for personal that's correct or even buy
a store no right it's from top to bottom
any employee be it full-time or
part-time that works more than 21 hours
a week 21 hours a week will be involved
in the incentive program and one of the
things that Tina will get into is what
we've seen over the years our part-time
employees used to bump up against that
28-hour window all the time our
part-time employees are now working 15
hours or a week or less so we need to
incentivize them to make us their
primary part-time employer so if they
are working for three different people
I'll take that extra shift a week at the
liquor admission to get to my 21 hours
so I can enjoy part of that bonus right
thank you
foreign
okay thank you so at this point thank
you very much for your questions uh I'll
turn it over to Tina to take you through
uh the rest of the program
thank you
so on page 30 what we have is our full
time and our part-time positions so
you'll see in the upper left corner it's
our authorized full-time positions both
filled and vacant with our vacancy rate
and you'll see that this year to date we
have the her highest vacancy rate at 12
percent we're currently recruiting for
40 positions with the majority of those
positions being in the stores
full time yeah the second chart is
full-time equivalent based on part-time
hours worked and as you can see we are
down to 285 full-time equivalent
so for a comparison in 21 we were when
we had record sales year we had 312
filled full-time positions and 358
part-time full-time equivalent for a
total of 670 full-time equivalent
currently we have 303 filled full-time
positions and 285 part-time full-time
equivalent for a total of 588 full-time
equivalent which is a difference of 82
full-time equivalent and this reduction
in position is the reason why you know
store hours have been reduced why we've
had to close doors and sales have been
impacted because we don't have the
people
um historically the outlets have been
supported by a fairly even mix of
full-time and part-time staff however
with the current trend of part-timers
working the less hours we found the need
to request additional full-time
positions in our 24-25 budget to offset
the decline in those part-time hours
so on page 31
this is our sales expense and revenue
trends for FY 20 to 22 and then the
estimates for 23 24 and 25 as we've
provided in our budget request
this is just to show how our budget
supports our sales and our revenues
and there are two rsas that are listed
on the bottom of the page the first
transfer requirement is under RSA 17616
and this is calculated into our plan
since it's the five percent of our prior
Year's gross profit and this is
identified online 7 in the table
and then there's RSA 126 AAA colon 3 and
this is not in our Revenue plan because
it's the additional funds requested by
HHS and that's line 9 on the table
and as identified as the granted
Advantage the monthly Revenue Focus
produced by Das reports the actual
transfer that's on line 10 but this is
not a true comparison to our plan
because they do it at the reduction of
the additional funds transferred to HHS
we also think it's important to mention
that we are on target for this year's
Revenue plan which is notable in this
ever-changing and unpredictable National
economy especially since the current
year plan was created two years ago
so we'll move on to page 32 for our
Revenue breakdown
so there are three main Revenue
categories that are listed and on slide
33 there's a chart that has a five-year
history
the categories are beer tax and permits
which is 30 cents a gallon sold on or
transferred for retail sales or to the
public for authorized licensees
liquor and wine Revenue this is the sale
of wine and spirits and accessories
through our outlets and our warehouses
to retail customers and on-premise
licensees which are restaurants and
lounges and off-premise licensees which
are the grocery stores and the
convenience stores
and then we have another Revenue source
which is primarily the licensing fees
but it also includes the direct shipping
permits and Lottery and other
miscellaneous Revenue
so moving on to page 34
this is a chart of the five-year history
of Revenue and expenses
and the line in the middle is the net
revenue transferred annually
we've gone from 157.4 million in 2018 to
165.4 million in FY 22.
and our operating expense ratio is
consistent around 30 to 32 percent
on page 35 is the budget broken down by
division for FY 22 and our FY 23
adjusted authorized and then the FY 24
and 25 budget requests and as you can
see marketing and Merchandising which
includes the outlets is the majority of
our budget and then next you have
Finance Enforcement office of the
commission and then workers comp and
unemployment comp
on page 36 is a graft of the five-year
transfer history and the estimates for
23 to 25 and broken down by the two rsas
governing our Revenue transfers first
you'll see is the alcohol fund started
out at 6.8 million in 18 and uh
increased to 11.5 million for FY 23
which we've already transferred and then
you have the next which is the granted
advantage that started in fy21 it was
8.2 million and this year we've already
transferred 7.2 million
then the next is the beer tax which is
consistent around the 13 million and the
last is the remaining net revenue from
liquor operations
and then on slide 37 representative I'm
sorry quick question
sure so there's a
tax so
a wine or
no they they purchase it from us through
the warehouse
oh
the tests on beer representative is a
gallonage tax so manuf from from the
distributors
and then on page 37 is our FY 22 sales
broken down by customer and category
type so Spirits wine and accessories and
this is just so you can see where our
sales come from
our retail sale Spirits were three 383
million or 50 percent of our business
retail wine 173 million or 22.6 percent
of our business and in total retail
accounts for 72.7 percent of our
business and then you can see the
breakdown for the other categories on
the pie charts
and a quick question sure going back I
think ringe had what 22 percent increase
in sales so it led me to start thinking
is it better for you I know it's
probably a too broad a question but to
own the stores or to lease stores what's
been your historical find as far as
owning versus leasing well originally uh
when I first started at the commission
and to this day we would need to get an
appropriation to build we'd have to
borrow the money we'd have to bond the
money and with the cost of materials and
equipment today were clearly better
leasing than we are building because of
the costs of of of anything a two by
four or a wiring anything that has to do
with building components is ridiculous
and one of the things that we've done
over the years is our outlay of cash in
a lease proposition is is very minimal
because we partner with our land Lords
in the first 10 years of the lease so a
lease with Market Basket Brix Moore or
whoever our our landlord is we go to
them and say this is what it costs us to
build this bill this is what it will
cost us to build this building
we're going to add that cost into the
additional square footage for the first
10 years of the lease so our outlay is
mint zero to minimal and it's spread out
over the first 10 years of the lease and
then drops off so not only do we get a
favorable rate from landlords because
we're the driver of traffic into the
plaza we're not having the outlay of of
State cash hurting State coffers we're
paying for between 350 and 550 an
additional square footage for the first
10 years and then that drops off most of
the leases at this point are 20 to 25
year leases and we found that that's the
best way to do it for us because it
keeps our cash flowing for the business
we don't need an appropriation we don't
have to pay the bonding and interest
representative hatch so the 350 550 is
that your square footage
that's the additional dollars per square
foot that will be for the first 10 years
of the lease representative all right
you used to pay me like five dollars a
square foot up in Berlin years ago but
that was pathetic
I threw me out after that I
wholeheartedly agree
so thank you
I guess I just never thought of it this
way so like a Hannaford's or a Market
Basket if they're selling wine since you
folks are the ones that sell wine in the
state they're buying their wine from you
correct we are the in in the state of
New Hampshire we are the retailer on our
end but we're also the wholesaler to
licensees on premise which is
restaurants and lounges and and any and
anybody else that has that type of
license and then we are the wholesaler
to uh the on off-premise licensees which
are the market baskets Hannaford's Shaws
Etc they buy our product from them they
buy our product from us and every month
we came out we come out with a special
flyer of deals for them to buy in so
when we get a a great price on something
we pass that price along to them so
right thank you what are the relative
prices
between the three groups the retail
store the on-premise and the off-premise
the the relative prices of the product
you know uh Kendall Jackson sure right
you sell it in your store for one price
you sell it to the to the um off-premise
for another price and to the on-premise
for some other price right well the the
prices are relatively close and what we
found and what is beneficial to our
business partners is when someone is at
their store and they're doing their
grocery shopping it's the convenience so
if they're there and they need one
bottle of wine they'll buy that one
bottle and pay the dollar more rather
than you know go into another store if
if we find the consumers if they're not
going to bulk buy uh they they tend to
pick up while they're shopping if it's
just one bottle so our goal is to get
them to come in and covered shall we say
if you only have to drive a mile we have
better prices yeah
okay so but
I guess my point was do you sell to
Hannaford
less per bottle than you sell to the
consumer
or is it all the same it's all the same
and actually the licensees get a 10
discount if they buy through the
warehouse as well so a licensee a
restaurant they can they can either have
the product shipped to them and pay for
the shipping or they can pick it up in
Bow which hundreds of licensees do and
get the 10 discount off of off of the
shelf or they can go into the stores and
take advantage of our sales which a lot
of licensees do smaller license these do
as well great thank you very much you're
welcome
so we'll just see on page 38 that we've
contributed uh 3.5 million with
non-profits across the state just
briefly and we we partner with our
suppliers worldwide national suppliers
and local Brokers to make those
donations and then on page 39 and 40 and
41 just some of the awards that the
Liquor Commission has won and some of
the accolades we've been given locally
and nationally we're very we have a very
competitive team and we're very grateful
for the recognition uh
that people like what we're doing so
we're very grateful for that
thank you very much and thank you are
there any further questions for the
Liquor Commission representative McGuire
yep let me ask about is there any sort
of substitution effect between liquor
and marijuana because all of our
surrounding states now have
um
recreational marijuana we don't right
have sales dropped in some way because
when that started
uh no but in in monitoring those sales
what we notice is much like people from
out of state come to New Hampshire to
buy their liquor
people from New Hampshire are going to
Maine Vermont and Massachusetts to buy
their cannabis products so in our
research uh those are the the New
Hampshire license plates are in the
three states that are surrounding us it
has not we have not seen an effect on
alcohol sales per se but we have
recognized that consumers of cannabis in
New Hampshire are visiting other states
to buy their product
so therefore you think if New Hampshire
joined these other states as far as
cannabis goes
you don't think your business would be
affected very much
well I certainly think if we had those
consumers if we took the same model with
alcohol with cannabis that we do with
alcohol and we were hyper competitive
and or better priced I think that we
would drive some of those consumers that
come here to buy alcohol to buy cannabis
while they were here obviously we always
look at
what are consumers doing when they're
here they're coming to recreate
four-wheeling the ocean the mountains so
they're buying gas they're paying rooms
and meals tax they're helping all our
small businesses by you know renting and
doing what they're doing so I think
there'd be some bleed over uh
positive bleed over to the state of New
Hampshire right just from a business
standpoint I understand thank you
all right seeing no further questions I
will recognize sitting in the back there
Lou dalessandro Senator dalessandro and
his wife keeping an eye on us
commissioner I'm sure we don't pick on
the Liquor Commission I believe anyway
thanks so much for your presentation I
guess we'll see you maybe next week or
the week after for years or Thursday yes
all right thank you thank you thank you
Mr chairman members of the committee
thank you very much thank you
foreign
laughs
all right we'll get this presentation
together and commissioner nice to see
you commissioner Caswell and if you
could I guess we're not neighbors so we
you could tell us who you are and
we'll get started welcome
so hi uh good afternoon Taylor Caswell
uh commissioner Department of Business
and economic Affairs this is Larry
harnois who is the state tourism
director uh who is here to talk I think
a little bit about that angle of what we
do at Bea
um thank you for having us today I think
it's a good opportunity to just sort of
do a little bit of a reset on uh Bea and
kind of where we are and uh in terms of
organization and budget and structure
and strategies for a few minutes and
then sort of see what you want to talk
about but
um we're still I guess in the world of
of uh state government relatively new uh
five years 2017 is when Bea was
established it was uh it is a uh two of
the major divisions that previously were
at what we used to call dread Department
of resource and economic development
that came over and formed the business
Department of Business and economic
Affairs and then we also have the
Department of Natural and cultural
resources so the two of those were the
outgrowths of that I've been the
commissioner of the department since
it's since it began in 2017.
um and our mission really is uh to to
Steward the state economy and the
quality of life I mean that's really
what we bury it we boil it down to uh
with our different organizations and
divisions within the department and I
can get into a little bit about how we
do that
uh so as far as our hierarchy goes we
have a number of different offices two
major divisions the division of Economic
Development and the division of travel
and tourism development which is the the
division that Laurie runs
DED as we call it also has within it all
of our business Recruitment and
expansion activity so we have three
staff people who work in that area their
job is effectively to work with
businesses from outside of the state and
sometimes within the state to help them
find new locations or to relocate
themselves here into New Hampshire
uh we have a retention team that is set
up regionally these are staff people who
are trained in Economic Development and
Business technical assistance and they
work with a number of Partners uh
together to bring services to existing
member uh members of the New Hampshire
business Community a small to large
business they build relationships in
their regions and and are a real touch
point for those businesses to a whole
host of different actions and uh and and
goals of what the the business are
trying to achieve within the state so we
do work with Department of
Transportation Department environmental
services
New Hampshire Employment Security
Department of energy and lots of others
to be that sort of touch point for the
business community
we have the office of international
Commerce so all the states International
activities and Export work is done
within Bea we have a staff of three
people in that in that office primarily
funded uh federally under the SBA step
program
but they are able to really be a
resource for businesses particularly
smaller and medium-sized businesses
they're looking to get into uh export
activity and identify markets around the
world for the types of products that
they're looking to sell
two of our newer divisions since we were
last year as I'm sure many of you are
aware uh the invest in age the housing
program is administered by Bea and a
staff of three people uh those are the
that's the 100 million dollar invest in
age program that comes to us through uh
federal arpa funds and uh and the
Broadband office is also within Bea also
funded with arpa funds and ultimately
with some infrastructure legislative
infrastructure funds from the federal
government
managing a number of different programs
to expand
the access for Broadband for people in
uncertain underserved locations
uh the office of Workforce opportunities
within us that's ministers the federal
Workforce Innovation Opportunity Act
funds with New Hampshire employment
security these are for adult
disadvantaged and youth programs one of
the major ways that we are able to
provide services both to people that are
looking to change positions but also
some disadvantaged uh uh members of the
of the population as well as work with
businesses that are experiencing
downsizing and layoffs we will work with
those businesses to help their employees
get relocated quickly into a new job
the Bureau of visitor Services is a is
the operational component of the
department we have a staff of
uh I don't know off the top of my head
but there's probably about seven or
eight staff here in Concord plus we have
a lot of part-time and full-time staff
they're Staffing the rest areas and
welcome centers around the state that's
under a contract with the Department of
Transportation
we have a an also addition this year is
the office of Planning and Development
they came over when we established the
uh the department of energy two years
ago and they broke up what we used to
call the office of strategic initiatives
and
um the office of Planning and
Development came to Bea at that point
and we've been happy to have them we
have our office of outdoor recreation
and Industry development this is another
federally funded program that gives us
an opportunity to connect the dots on
economic development and outdoor
recreation and tourism
um travel and tourism is uh really one
of the major functions of the department
I'm going to let Lori talk about that in
just a minute but
um the division of travel tourism
development is the marketing engine of
the state the marketing engine for
tourism
um I guess we get some of the nice
pictures that are in some and in your uh
handout today that come from that but
also I've just been seeing some very
significant results uh for the
Investments that we make into that and
again I'll let Lori expand on that a
little bit in a moment
are there any questions so far
representative Abel sorry I went through
a lot of stuff there well that's fine
so under arpa we have to have the funds
obligated by the end of 2024 and then we
have to have those funds uh fully
expended by the end of 2026.
so that would be
as uh in relation to the invest in each
housing program
the programs that we are now funding for
Housing Development have 18-month
windows on them for that reason
sure you said for the housing you had a
hundred million but I didn't hear you
say a number for the Broadband yeah so
the so we're getting we have different
sources under Broadband some of which we
haven't got the funding yet so we don't
know what the total is but to date we uh
we have under the the old care the
capital projects fund under arpa the
number is 122 million dollars for that
program we expect probably at least that
much when we get the infrastructure uh
funding under What's called the bead
program which we expect to see later
this year maybe this summer from the
federal government
representative McGuire thank you Mr
chairman hi what does the 120 million
get us what for for Broadband so where
we are with that is we have uh we we've
done two rounds of what we call the
Broadband connect program so this is a
program that is designed to get as many
unserved and underserved locations uh
into the served and uh uh access to
high-speed internet as quickly as
possible
um and so we did Issue one award back I
think it was late last year around
December to New Hampshire Electric
Cooperative for 50 million dollars they
are underway and uh and stringing fiber
uh through the areas that they're
responsible for and that they put in
their uh application so that will total
uh I think it's I recall is around 23
000 new unserved and underserved
locations and that's all where they are
and all that is all on our website if
you'd like to see the list I can
certainly get it for you we're going to
be issuing at we expect to have at the
next executive council meeting the uh
the award for the second round of this
program and that we expect to be
somewhere near that number or another 20
000 unserved and underserved locations
primarily in rural areas in the state in
the northwest of Concord so once a
customer
um you signs up for the service they
would still pay their fees similar to
what a customer in Manchester or
somebody else somewhere else would pay
is that right that would be how it would
it would work right I mean you get
hooked up and you have that accessed if
you want to have that internet speed
yeah you pay the same price gotcha thank
you
representative hatch
good afternoon good to see you
um just just one of my
areas of concern are continuing concern
is our
visitor Services
i.e.r rest areas
um
I was wondering if it would be possible
to get together something that would
inform us what you need to have them
open with more frequency than we
currently experience
um it's just um
in my mind a little bit aggravating
driving up the interstate whether it be
89 or 93 and having our rest areas
closed
in a
just leaves a very poor impression for
our visitors I'm sure and um
and in here Bureau of visitor Services
provides visitors with necessary and
requested information is enhance the
visitors guest experience
um and it ensures uh what visiting
centers are welcoming uh closed is not
very welcoming yeah so what can we do to
address that it's been an ongoing issue
with me it drives me nuts we're a state
that relies heavily on tourism and um I
would think we'd be able to do a little
bit of job in that area well I share
your frustration I think the major
problem is that we pay twelve dollars an
hour for people to sit in those vest
areas and maintain them and clean the
bathrooms and mow The Lawns that sort of
thing and it's not anywhere near what
the market pays for those we have most
of the services in this in the rest
areas that are open are on our borders
uh primarily where we focus those we
have only one area that has had a
difficult time staying open at all in on
um which one is it that's Sutton Sutton
has been a difficult one but we have uh
you know we just hired someone buddy to
work at the Seabrook Center and she
lives in Concord so they're willing to
make for whatever reason she's willing
to make that drive over to the Seabrook
rest area but we are particularly in
places like Colebrook and Littleton
um we are subject to having staff so if
if we don't have the staff to be there
on a given day then that obviously
impacts our operational capabilities but
that you know speaking for Bob Vashon
who is the chief of this of this Bureau
he would very much share your
frustration he is very
inclined to have these operations be
what they are expected to be I think
given the circumstances and given the
labor market
um he's done a good job at keeping the
key ones available and open where you
know in the 93 quarters in the mass
where we see the most people but it is
you know quite simply a a question of
Workforce
so I guess my question is is what do we
need to do to change those circumstances
what do we need to do to assure that
there's adequate Personnel to have these
visitor centers open I you probably
would be maybe not amazed at how many
comments I get from individuals about
that I'm still hearing about the one in
Shelburne closing
way too often
um and um I see I and I think it's a
serious issue and I think it needs to be
addressed so to say the problem is we
only paid twelve dollars an hour that
doesn't answer my word my query is what
do you need
from us to address that issue and assure
that we have adequate personnel there to
maintain them and have an open
um when visitors might expect them to be
and when they could provide the service
that is important for to maintain the
visitor
we have everything we need to operate
the centers except the people and and
that is not a cons it's it's
inconsistent I would say in the uh in
the main travel corridors we haven't had
as much of difficulty in getting those
staffed and it is as a result sometimes
of asking people to travel quite a
distance to be able to staff those
centers
um but it does in some other areas put
us in a position of being unable to stay
open at seven days that that we're all
hoping to be able to be open well I just
need to know
again what you need
so that we can have adequate personnel
there to have them open if it's we need
more money to pay adequate salary to
those individuals to attract them to
that job that's what you need
um there's a couple other things there's
um I think I brought it to your
attention before a few years ago the
csep program and things like that where
you can get help for next to nothing and
sometimes uh nothing in their elderly
but they are very reliable uh and and
good people to have on board
um
and I I think we need to pay a little
more attention there and I just need to
know what you need if you if we have to
pay them 900 an hour what that would
take
I'm being extreme yeah that's that's to
make my point yeah and I understand
representative we've talked about this
you know over the years I I it is very
much a frustration and a challenge I
don't think it's all that different than
a lot of other businesses that I talk to
on a regular basis that can't staff
their manufacturing facilities their
health care facilities I know we have we
have a real labor shortage in the state
and these jobs unfortunately are at a
point sort of within that income
category that's near the bottom if
you're not working for us at 12 or 13 an
hour you can work at Dunkin Donuts for
15 or 16. so we're we're in a
competition I'm aware of all that yeah I
know so again back to my question I want
you to ask me what I asked you so we
have a clear understanding what what I
need to know from you
so you so if I could I guess I'm it's
probably frustrated as representative
hatch do you need to pay 15 an hour I
think that's what he's trying to get out
of you to you need to pay 15 or 16 an
hour we just heard from The Liquor
Commission that has an incentive program
because they're having trouble to get
people in so they're going to put some
incentive programs together uh I've
heard some from some of my friends uh
female friends say they're disgusted to
go to these rest areas and use the
facilities and you go and I do a lot of
traveling around New England Maine New
York Vermont they have beautiful rest
areas and they're staffed so they're
often staffed by private sector so the
ones in Maine you know where you stop
they have people who work for uh
Kentucky Fried Chicken or or Dunkin
Donuts in those centers and we have a we
have centers like that like that in
Hooksett North and southbound and those
as you know are well staffed it's when
you get to the to the the facilities
that are federally required that are
just a center with a fireplace and two
bathrooms and some brochures that this
becomes a more difficult component and
there are federal regulations about what
you can put in those centers so we can't
we've for example we went to the
Intervale Center up in North Conway or
an interview just outside of North
Conway and uh we asked if the local
chamber would work with us to help staff
that facility and then they they were
not willing to do that and then we
worked with White Mountains attractions
because they have a facility in Lincoln
that's not one of our welcome centers
but it serves as that if they would want
to do one on the other side of the White
Mountains and they also said no so it it
it it's not like we're not looking for
Solutions we have worked with a
department Department of administrative
services to address the pay issue we did
get the clerks that work for the Bureau
of visitor services to pay level that is
similar to people who work for state
parks so you know lining up all the
different categories that they have
there and that has helped to some degree
but we still have challenges in some
areas of of the state as it relates to
these so we have 12 of these centers and
as I have said our goal is to keep the
main transportation corridors staffed
seven days some we're there most of the
time I would say 80 to 90 percent we're
in that category and if we're not it's
going to be like a Tuesday it's not
going to be on a weekend but some of the
centers outside of that sometimes get a
little bit more difficult
so what's the specific problem with uh
up in Lebanon the one just outside of
Lebanon 89.
I know that we've heard from reps and
Eddie or they just bought a parties
there and well the porta potty thing is
another whole is another whole issue
right I mean they're those you know we
we contract that service with a third
party who are in the same boat as we are
as far as staff so we have had
situations where I've heard the same
thing that you've heard about the
condition of the porta potties because
somebody didn't show up to work on
Sunday that paid that drives the porta
potty truck and it got left and so
you've got a whole weekend in there and
that it is is not a place that you want
to be but again I I you know we have a
contract with someone that's supposed to
deliver they don't have somebody to
drive the truck they don't show up and
that's that's the situation we get in
representative McGuire followed by
representative evil thank you so just
more detail do the people who work in
these centers are they full-time or
part-time it's a mix
okay mostly part mostly part-time so
that one is straight pay right going
from 12 to 16 or something would help
yes okay
um and what about a greater use of
Granite State ambassadors
so uh we do use Granite State
ambassadors in the Hooksett uh welcome
centers I don't know sort of the status
of their use of their availability in
the other centers I would have to check
on that but we do not use Granite State
ambassadors in the other centers
yeah and it
I think I think some of them have
training I should say right you know the
greatest State ambassadors do a training
program and our staff is trained by them
but they're just not actually giving us
the individuals yeah but I think you
could push it a little more I mean they
take I do think you they take a little
money from you right to run the things
but
um but I think that's a possibility of
getting more people not to clean
bathrooms but to meet visitors yeah I am
one myself so
yeah
who knew this would be the Hot Topic
somehow it often becomes well so I'm
just going back in time I remember there
was like this big rigmarole between
D.O.T and you folks as to who owned the
facilities who was maintaining them
who was responsible for mulling and and
then there was going to be an mou I mean
yeah so that all got worked out so it's
now very clear so dot owns yes but you
run the whole show correct we manage the
facilities and that mou was something
something that was a source of
a lot of discussion uh prior to be a and
when we came in and again our bureau
chief Bob Vashon worked with Dot and we
got that all set so we're in a very
happy place with them right now yes
[Music]
representative hatch thank you back to
my original question when might I expect
an answer in terms of what I need to
keep the centers open yes staff I need
staff and what you need to do what you
need to do in terms of finances or
otherwise to get that stuff that well I
don't want to just off the top of my
head but it's going to be more than what
we're paying now
a week or so
thank you
all right commissioner moving right
along
um maybe what I might do at this point
is maybe turn it over to Lori uh to talk
about uh the the marketing work that we
do at the department and walk you
through some of those
components and then I'll just come back
right at the end and talk a little about
what we're looking at for the next for
the next two years and then we can
continue discussing whenever you'd like
that works sounds good well thank you
for having me today
um so just a little bit more about the
marketing efforts that the division of
travel and tourism does so we are a
staff of nine people we have a lot of
different contractors that we work with
Granite State ambassadors is one of them
um but other contractors like an ad
agency PR firms
um research firms so uh it's a really a
multi-faceted approach that we take in
promoting New Hampshire as a travel
destination
um our total budget is about 9.5 million
and just give you some comparison on how
we are with our most competing states
because as you know now that we are back
in or we're recovering from covid
competition is going to be fierce
because people have lots of different
options to go to to travel so oftentimes
We compare ourselves
based upon population
geographic location with the state of
Maine specifically Vermont as well but
it's a little different than what what
New Hampshire's characteristics that are
so the state of Maine's total budget is
about double of what we have to spend to
Market our destination so it's very
important that we do it uh very smartly
data driven as we move through this and
in a variety of different tactics we
also as the commissioner had pointed out
that we are really the marketing arm for
the state
so what we and I I guess the Silver
Lining with the pandemic was that we
really uh began working very closely
with other state agencies
um in terms of the need for the tourism
industry but a variety of different
um sectors so one we've also worked with
like the DMV on CDL uh marketing
campaigns we've worked with Employment
Security on trying to recruit Workforce
because we really see today's Travelers
as tomorrow's Talent so it's a great
um PR if you will campaign to convince
Travelers that hey you probably would
want to consider living here working
here being part of a New Hampshire's
land landscape so as I mentioned we do
this through a variety of different ways
we through the pandemic we actually
adjusted how the target markets that we
promote New Hampshire in historically we
always looked at New England New York
and Eastern Canada with the pandemic we
expanded our marketing reach to a 600
mile radius of New Hampshire and we saw
some great return on that so we're
continuing with those efforts
also moving forward to continue to
Market in Canada as the borders have
opened again it's very critical for us
to retain those Travelers that had come
down to New Hampshire before the
pandemic but as well as our
International or overseas Travelers
um specifically we're seeing trends that
the traveler from Eastern uh Western
Europe excuse me are getting back to the
levels that they were before the
pandemic to the U.S so it's important
for us to also be targeting those
Travelers because they are not weather
dependent they stay longer spend more
money so it's very important for us to
keep them as part of our marketing mix
um we are really uh we I think in your
packet we've got some examples of some
of the ads that we've done but it's a
wide variety of whether it's television
ads Billboards or out of home ads we do
these destination takeovers so there we
like took over back Bays uh uh t-stop
Station in Boston
um we have a lot of digital advertising
as well so that we can really track how
the traveler
um uh from the beginning part of the
funnel the marketing funnel to how they
where they choose to come on their final
vacation location
um so we do that we um we so we measure
that through our return on investment
and it's a very conservative uh
um uh uh estimate that they put forward
our research firm which is Smarty so
they really look at the total they
survey our whole the areas where we
market look at who
um has seen the ads who we have
influenced and who actually has come to
New Hampshire so those are really more
of a data driven approach to prove the
investment that for every dollar that we
spend it Returns the latest one that
continues to increase year over year but
the latest is about a sixteen dollars
return on investment we also as we're
looking at the
um the workforce and
um uh just the the migration rate of New
Hampshire we see that continuously
moving forward and increasing which is a
a positive
approach for the state so that is
encouraging and we'd like to continue on
that as well
and the last thing that I wanted to
bring up is that we continue to look at
the state as a whole and the best
strategy on how we can develop and
Market uh the state as a tourism
destination so we are continuing to do
that we're working through a strategy
now for the next five years on the plan
and so that we can really historically
we've always looked at number of
visitors and how much they spend but we
want to make sure that we're looking at
all data points that we are looking at
for those Travelers that are going to
also make sure that we have a
sustainable tourism and moving forward
so that's really kind of the the plan of
attack for tourism for us
questions
representative from Mont Vernon
I'm kind of interested in the
demographics of the state but I'm also
interested in the demographics of the
tourists
and who do you rely on I know the
University
has a section there where they do some
pretty good work on demographics
who who do you people rely on
yeah well you could speak to tourism I
think uh as far as you're absolutely
right Carson Institute and the
University of New Hampshire has a really
robust program of tracking the the
migration numbers and the number of
people that are the net migration number
is really what we're looking at
um when you when you kind of get to that
point and you look at what they've been
able to uh you know track over the last
several years and compare that to other
Northeastern states we come out on top
every every year so it's not in and of
itself you know Gonna Change uh huge
numbers and you're talking in a couple
of thousand people probably each year
but that is a in positive territory is a
very different place than where we have
been in the past
yeah and in regards to the uh tourism
visitor we look at specific so for
example we Market in in New York right
so
um we we adjust like we had
um so Marketing in New York is very
expensive
um especially in the city so actually we
had started off there many years ago but
then as we wanted to really drill down
on what typical traveler is going to
come to New Hampshire from New York most
likely right in the heart of like you
know New York City it's a lot of
visitors they're not necessarily
residents so we've adjusted to specific
communities around that would be more
typical to come to New Hampshire that
have that income level that would be
worthwhile for us to try to to encourage
them to consider New Hampshire as a
travel destination and we do that in all
those main target markets that I
mentioned earlier
another question representative Griffin
so kind of piggybacking on
representative Griffin's question how do
you determine like for instance the
average taxable trip spending you
obviously don't have the commissioner
standing down in Nashville to stopping
cars periodically to see how much they
spent so how do you determine those
numbers yeah that's a great question so
we work with our research firm which is
Smarty insights and they survey
Travelers that are from these core
markets that we Market to and they use a
benchmarking
analysis that's based upon National Data
that evaluates typically what the spend
would be so we take that amount per
traveler and base it upon the
incremental visitors so how many did we
influence to come to New Hampshire and
that gives you that total spend
representative evil did you have a
question thank you will you um use the
word that I was sort of thinking about
making your tourism sustainable could
you talk about the effect of the weather
snow foliage
yeah whatever you want to say that gives
me heartburn right yeah so um that's a
great question and so yeah it's very
important for us to look at sustainable
tourism so in the sense of climate so
that how can we help those businesses
that are in the state adjust their how
their operations are so many ski areas
have adjusted to add other activities
such as zip lining
um uh Fat Tire biking a variety of
different other activities that they can
do to help balance out those that
shorter ski season that we're seeing but
we're also looking at sustainability in
the sense of such things as our
infrastructure like uh for Ev vehicles
and you know knowing that
um States like other states like Vermont
and Massachusetts have a pretty
aggressive uh look at that that we want
to make sure that New Hampshire doesn't
fall behind in the sense that if people
don't have a a place to charge their
vehicle would they not come so looking
at as a whole and for sustainable
tourism in that sense so
I might just add to that I mean this is
a challenge right I mean you've we've
we've got a tourism Market that is based
in large part on outdoor recreation and
access to natural resources and all
those sorts of things
but as we have seen over the last couple
years particularly since covid just a
tremendous increase in the number of
people that are looking to be able to
take advantage of those types of assets
so you know if you've been to Franconia
Notch during the summer the last couple
of years we've worked with dncr and
state parks and Dot to address people
parking literally on the side of the
interstate in minivans with their kids
and getting out you know with logging
trucks going by this that was a
completely untenable situation and we
came together you know state parks
particularly Franconia Notch state park
it came with a you know they've got some
Vans and we started to have people Park
up at the up at the Peabody lift and
then we would drive them down
but
um the increase in activity as you will
hear like from Scott Mason at fish and
game and the number of rescues and the
way that state parks is moving towards a
reservation based system to be able to
control crowds these are all aspects of
what I would say is a post-covered
outdoor recreation slash tourism
strategy all seated in the fact that
that is a not an infinite natural
resource and uh at the same time trying
to grow and maintain a really critical
industry and employer for the State of
New Hampshire so that is really our
challenge right now and we're working
with as uh as Laurie pointed out a firm
to kind of give us a little bit more
insight as to how we might be able to
accomplish that as part of a state
strategy where we're not just purely
just you know measuring how many people
came and how much they spent I mean I
think we need to go a little deeper than
that and talk about ways that we can get
people to go to other areas instead of
just a Franconia notch or just to the
Appalachian Trailhead or just to die in
his baths you know the places that are
just clogged with people in the middle
of the summer time so it is a challenge
and we want to be able to accommodate
those people and give them a very strong
experience when they come here and in
the end that probably has
some strong connection to what we end up
with
other questions representative McGuire
thank you so you mentioned uh migration
and I read an interesting statistic
recently that 30 percent of all home
sales in our state are to people who
don't live in New Hampshire
and of that 30 percent over half are
people from Massachusetts
so to the extent that your marketing and
and the other thing about Massachusetts
they just recently passed this horrible
um tax millionaires tax so so you know
they're already primed to move and and
you know get the the boot is kicking
them out the door kind of thing so for
for your marketing
dollars do you do you kind of over
Market extra in Massachusetts do you
push a little there
well I mean you've you're you're you're
you're you're correct representative and
that is uh got to continue to be a big
part of our challenge Airbnb uh uh it's
a good example in a lot of areas like
the Mount Washington Valley and
increasingly up in Littleton Bethlehem
and those areas uh you have
um people that can afford a house in
Bethlehem that work in Boston so they'll
buy the house aim to go there someday
but in the meantime they're going to
rent it to all their friends from Boston
uh not so bad for tourism at least in
terms of that dollar figure but pretty
bad for tourism when you've now taken
away a home that could have been an
employee that worked at the you know at
the ski area or at the restaurant or
whatever so these are all significant
challenges I would say that they are uh
probably more in the side of influenced
by market and by cost and by other other
sort of financial drivers than they are
by marketing uh the marketing component
I think gets the people interest just
didn't get some here we've been doing
that for some time we're seeing that
increase but a lot of it is really based
in the market dynamics where as
expensive as it is for people who live
in the North Country uh in in in
relative comparison to where they've
been in the last few years it's
extremely cheap for people that are from
uh you know outside of the Boston area
so that becomes a challenge and you're
you're also correct we are seeing
increases of home sales particularly in
Southern New Hampshire since that
millionaires tax or whatever we want to
call it was passed in Massachusetts uh I
think I saw somewhere that a house just
sold on the Seacoast for something like
25 million dollars so
um it's it's we're getting into the
category that we've seen in a lot of
other states on the housing thing
thank you
that's a very interesting statistical
situation I guess it is and the Airbnb
thing I look I get it but it's sort of
like what Uber did to taxis and and and
try as you may in a couple of different
jurisdictions to try to get at that from
a statutory or a legal standpoint it
didn't you know there wasn't any real
basis for that there was doing maybe
increased cost here or there but we
can't say you know straight out like you
can't Airbnb your house I mean we can't
do that
um there's probably other ways that you
can get around the edges but whether
that fundamentally turns you know change
it to die I don't know but it's
a pretty interesting question and when
the dynamic
always a lot of challenges
representative evil thanks well I was
just going to say we just sold our house
and I had five offers you know like that
and everyone bought one they were
looking at having just a second house in
New Hampshire
and it was a family house and I was
determined that it would go to the
family so that's where it went yeah but
you know if you're if you're not mindful
of that it just keeps sucking things out
away from families making everything
yeah and we're trying to on the other
side you know facilitate more affordable
housing Workforce housing make
investments in those categories but you
know the market itself is taking away a
lot of you know what was there to start
with so
unquestionably uh what the biggest
challenge in my view the biggest
challenge to to the economy is housing
and that's I think good examples of why
that is
it's not all zoning to me
uh representative McGuire well just
along this discussion I'm on the
planning board for my town we had a
developer coming visited us this week
who wants to build a 15-unit development
and he says he simply cannot build a
four hundred thousand dollar house
anymore these are going to be 550
000 houses you know it's just incredible
I was at a development uh this past week
uh multi-family uh I think it was like
maybe 50 units and while we were there
and these are energy efficient units
they're under construction right now
they all have these you know cruddy
looking doors on the front of them it's
because the doors haven't been available
uh and they ordered them I think he said
like 15 months ago and while we were
there they the truck actually pulled in
with the doors and everybody was super
excited about but I mean it's an
interesting conversation because what it
does the the whole business of
development has completely changed as a
result of supply chain challenges labor
force challenges all these costs that
we've been talking about
the way that they develop these things
and the amount of money that they have
to front in order to order the doors
probably before they're even permitted
uh in order to make the the finances
pencil out that's you know that's going
to Ripple through everything zoning and
all the rest of it so we are in the
midst of a lot of change and most of it
due to covid
very interesting discussion you know
we're wrestling with affordable housing
but because of our
tax situation attracting people with
money here that are buying up the
property so those folks that are looking
for the affordable housing are even
pushed out further yes interesting
well very oh further question
Representative no I was going to say
I think we have to do something along
the lines of allowing more multi-family
you know places where because my town
zones away multi-family right and so we
have to we we can push that a bit
in my opinion
I would agree with that you know density
is not a bad thing right and
um where we have been able to see
multi-family developments in communities
that are willing to have those there
have been pretty tangible benefits to
those communities from an economic and a
community standpoint and those are not
the types of units that are going to be
Airbnb not in maybe in some cases but in
in most cases not yeah a duplex is is
not twice the cost of a of a single
family home right right you know sure
yes representative Griffin thank you
commissioner I wonder if you can ask
this question
we
I served on the uh
Commission on demographic change
and we had a lot of people come in from
UNH and other places and basically got a
pretty solid education
we didn't do much with that
one of the questions that was raised at
the time that we didn't get an answer
for is a few years ago we changed the
state law
so that you could have an accessory
building area on your lawn
and the idea of that was to promote
affordable housing on the theory that a
lot of people would build that kind of
housing for their in-laws and over time
those units
would become available as affordable
units
but nobody seems to have any statistics
on how that works have you seen any
thing on that I would say if they're
there it's with New Hampshire housing I
mean they have been running an Adu
program and I know that they have you
know they are the repository of a lot of
data that we often will use for for
these types of questions so I'd be happy
to check in with them and see if they
have any information and get it to you
but I don't know it off the top of my
head I'm sorry
I believe those are the people that we
asked
well this is a few years ago maybe
they've had some time to look into it
I'll ask for you
yep
well seeing no further questions thank
you very much it was very useful
presentation I think for all of us and
and our representative hatch looks
forward to how we can get people into
the rest areas in the next week or two
thanks have a good weekend thank you for
having us it's always a pleasure
foreign